اوكرانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي يدا بيد هذه
الصوره التقطت في شهر فبراير شباط الماضي
واليوم يريد الرئيس الاوكراني التقدم في
ملف انضمام بلاده الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
بخطوات
متسارعه مهمتنا هي الاقتراب من معايير
وممارسات الاتحاد الاوروبي واعتمادها
اوكرانيا ستصبح ضمن الاتحاد الاوروبي
وسنحقق ذلك وذلك بفضل التحول الذي شهدته
بلادنا بشكل خاص التحول الذي وبالتاكيد في
مصلحه
شعبنا منحت كياف صفه مرشح لعضويه الاتحاد
الاوروبي في يونيو حزيران من عام 2022 بعد
اسابيع قليله من بدء الحرب ضد روسيا لكن
من اجل الانتقال الى المرحله التاليه اي
فتح مفاوضات الانضمام حددت المفوضيه
الاوروبيه لكيف سبعه معايير حتى الان
استوفت منها معيارين وهما تكوين هيئات
قضائيه رفيعه المستوى واعاده هيكله قطاع
الاعلام ليتوافق مع المعايير الاوروبيه
كما تم احراز تقدم ملموس فيما يتعلق
بالمعيار الثالث والمتمثل في انتقاء قضاه
المحكمه الدستوريه كل ذلك كفيل بارضاء
رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه اود ان اعبر لكم عن مدى اعجابنا
بالاصلاحات التي قمتم بها في خضم الحرب
واعلم انكم بصدد انهاء الاصلاحات الجاريه
واذا كان الامر كذلك فانا على ثقه من ان
اوكرانيا ستكون قادره على تحقيق هدفها
الطموح المتمثل في الانتقال الى المرحله
التاليه من عمليه
الانضمام حتى الان تظل كيف مطالبه
باستفزاز ومنع غسيل الاموال بالاضافه الى
حمايه الاقليات والتخفيف من نفوذ
الاوليغارش واذا اعطت بروكسل الضوء الاخضر
لمفاوضات انضمام اوكرانيا فان هذا لن يكون
سوى خطوه اولى وسيتعين بعد ذلك على الدول
الاعضاء ال7 الموافق على هذا القرار او
عدم الموافقه عليه